10h15 passé deux minutes 22h17
exactement si moore joignez bien entendu
édition spéciale consacrée à cette
déferlante terroriste à new york à
washington
des scènes incroyables ont fait un
nouveau point nouveaux commentaires sur
ces images signées daniel wolfromm
l'image est terrible presque irréel ce
en direct filmée par la télévision
américaine le boeing et ses dizaines de
passagers percute en une trajectoire
parfaite le haut de la tour du world
trade center
vingt minutes plus tôt un premier
appareil s'était encastré dans l'une des
deux tours jumelles provoquant déjà un
terrible incendie
c'est la panique
il est 9h ce matin et des milliers
d'employés sont déjà au bureau certains
appellent à l'aide
d'autres préfèrent se jeter par les
fenêtres
[Musique]
les deux boeing détourné avec leurs
passagers ont été volontairement dirigé
par les pirates versés tours symboles de
la puissance financière américaine une
heure plus tard même scénario à
washington un troisième appareil
s'écrase sur le pentagone cette fois ci
le ministère de la défense
le cerveau militaire des etats unis
presque simultanément à new york une des
deux tours s'effondrent sur elle-même
110 étages 300 mille tonnes d'acier de
béton
[Musique]
vingt minutes plus tard explosion et
destruction complète de sa soeur jumelle
[Musique]
images d'apocalypse le sud de manhattan
disparaît sous la poussière le maire de
new york fait évacuer le sud de la ville
et parle d'un nombre terrible de
victimes sans avancer le moindre bilan